people jump to this framing because it's
easy to point to Terminator and Skynet
but it's it's almost like leaping to the
Moon before we've even invented the
transistor I mean it's a it's hundreds
of years away I it's really unhelpful
there are many practical near-term
operational capabilities that you can
predict just as I've tried to describe
and you can then use those to wrestle
with what are the consequences for the
nation state how does this change our
businesses what does this mean for our
governments so in general I don't make
those predictions I'm very skeptical
that the super intelligence framing is
is useful to us what about the other one
that you know backyard one of be AI
commentators are always talking about
which is the odds of existential
catastrophe what are the odds that we
will wipe ourselves out with this again
I mean I think very very low I I really
think what's very low I I I think in
infanty small such that it's not worth
putting the reason I asked you that is
because I asked one of your um someone
somewhat similar to you what this was oh
very low they said and I said what's
very low oh about 5% I was
like yeah so you think it's infinites
zero okay well that's a good place to
end on all right we're going to open now
to your questions and questions um from
the online audience this is a good
question from Kitty hadock who asks what
will be the impact of all that computer
power on our carbon emissions or will AI
be able to enhance productivity so we
reduce carbon elsewhere yeah another hot
take on this very low and really
inconsequential the amount of carbon
that we spend on our data centers is
genuinely minuscule relatively speaking
secondly most of that happens in
completely renewable data centers Google
and Microsoft are both entirely 100%
renewable Google actually owns the
largest wind farm uh uh largest set of
wind farms in the world um one of the
projects that I worked on whilst I was
at Deep Mind was making the entire Wind
Farm Fleet 20% more efficient so you
know right from the outset they have
been focused on this I'm not saying
there aren't other environmental
consequences like the use of you know
galenium and Cobalt in the actual chip
manufacturer and so on but I honestly
think that relative to the benefits that
we're seeing and with respect to the
absolute cost of carbon per unit of
computation it's very very small and and
just to follow up to that because an
argument I have often heard is that the
cost of electricity and the access to
power will be a constraint on the
development of these AIS and their
proliferation do you also think that's
not true no I I I I think that's not
true I mean I think that's not true I I
I think that some data centers will be
at the 100 megawatt scale which is maybe
a single digigit percentage of a small
cities electricity consumption but we're
talking about a very small number at the
100 megawatt scale I mean that really is
enormous nothing like that exists today
so don't don't worry about the carbon
consequences of the actual AIS um from
the audience questions here yes lady
here in the second
row thank you um uh sheru from uh number
of Education
hello education companies that use AI um
my question to you is um if you think
about two industries say Healthcare and
education and you think about um the
applications that uh that that ai ai has
could you choose between the two which
you would hold um the most hope for and
um how should they be thinking about it
should they be thinking about procuring
it and how do you safely or procure it
well um or again as you said you could
produce it but some of those
organizations may not be in a position
to produce it anytime soon so if you're
a procurer um how do you do that well
and what are some of the Frameworks that
should be used for that yeah thank you
that's a great question I mean on the
I'm probably most excited in terms of
the immediate near-term impact about
education I mean these models are
already being used I think the primary
use case of chat GPT is in fact homework
help and people often think oh my kids
are you know copying and copy pasting
but actually if you actually watch the
way they're using these models and many
people use our models up high for
exactly this reason it's a
conversational interaction much like an
enthusiastic teacher might speak to a
child about the interest that they have
so the child or the Learner in general
gets to phrase the question in exactly
their style picking on exactly the thing
that they're interested in asking the
odd obscure poorly phrased you know not
complete picture type question and of
course the AI is infinitely patient
provides really detailed mostly factual
information I mean it's not always
perfect but it will be perfect and I
think that's an unbelievable um
meritocratic gain for everybody I mean I
think we need to picture a world in 5
years time where the best education in
the world completely personalized
entirely factually accurate is available
to absolutely everybody who wants it on
the planet pretty much for
free which sounds amazing um how do you
go from where we are now to that uh to
that that world I I think the beauty of
the um of these models is that they have
an inherent tendency to proliferate and
get smaller I mean that this is the
upside of proliferation they spread
because everybody wants access everybody
wants to integrate them you know there
are so many competing models now the
cost of um the the the the cost of
buying a model per word so if you're
building an app for example you'll go to
one of the three or four big model
creators and you pay per word that cost
has come down
70x since
January because we're all competing with
each other right so that means that you
can now take a regular app that you
might have been developing for you know
years in its current instantiation and
add a conversational widget in fact
we're doing this at The Economist with
the ecobot secret project underway
clearly not so secret
anymore thank
you
sorry and
you and you integrate you integrate the
conversational um element into your
existing workflow so you should be able
to ask any question in the style and the
theme of your brand about the specific
content that you have and it will be
like a widget it's like a plug andplay
widget that you can put anywhere in the
app and that's what I mean about prod
eration obviously everybody finds that
useful and you'll be able to use that
tool as a in a low code or no code
environment it'll you know if you see
how the image generation models are
being integrated into Adobe today if
you're already a user of adobe you're
you're using the absolute Cutting Edge
AI models in a drag and drop way like no
training required you if you're building
a new website today it's drag and drop
you just grab a little widget and plop
it over here and sudden you have you
know a YouTube player with your video
and suddenly you have a conversational
you know interaction with a language
model that is conditioned over all your
data so I think it's important to wrap
your head around the idea that this is
going to be widely available to
everybody there isn't going to be an
access issue and the risk and harm comes
from mitigating the downsides of the Bad
actors who might use you you know use it
for nefarious purposes but the upsides
are
incredible Let's Get It Go lot lot and
lots of hands let's get yes lady there
but I'm going to get one from online
while you get your microphone and the
one from online is a question from sa
Paulo gosh your audience is is going
come from a long way um Renee dealo Jr
asks when you say we will solve this and
that who is this we Humanity good
question corporations the UN or Elon
Musk I definitely hope it's not Elon
Musk I think of it as the kind
of the community of researchers
inventors and creators there's this sort
of dialogue sometimes you see Snippets
of it on Twitter sometimes you see it in
the research papers that academics
publish you know you see it in the blogs
and the products that big companies
produce there is this sort of unfolding
you know evolving mold of an ecosystem
which is referencing each other creating
and evolving and so when I say we I
certainly don't mean me at inflection um
my current company I just mean the the
the ecosystem of humanity like we're
we're trending collectively in a
direction of invention and creation just
one tiny does that ecosystem include
Chinese
scientists so 10 years ago Chinese
scientists were not really part of the
conversation they weren't really very
relevant over the last 10 years they
have launched onto the scene producing
very high quality research cre ative
research you know the old stereotype was
that they can only copy and steal again
I think a demonization partly by Elon
Musk actually who was a big proponent of
this idea that they were just robbing
our intellectual property and there was
some of that but largely they were just
as creative as us and they wanted to get
access to these tools to build their own
businesses and and provide new products
and services for their own citizens for
the same reason as we do and so if you
start from that assumption then of
course they're participating in this
ecosystem of course they're creating
incredible models you know they have
their own constraints with respect to
censorship and that has slowed them down
by a little bit but they're actually not
going to be that far behind now I mean
there are some issues with the export
controls and they don't have access to
Cutting Edge models but I don't think
that's going to hold them back for very
long
that